bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal sur TVfil 78 pour
débuter la semaine en ce lundi 24
novembre nous reviendrons notamment sur
la 30e campagne d'hivers des Restos du
cœur les distributions alimentaire début
de nouveaux records devraient être
batttu comment réagissent les bénévoles
comment s'organisent-ils dans les
iveline invité Henry FAL responsable
communication pour le département devant
les incivilités les violences et les
trafics dans certains quartiers les élus
de la verrière mobilise les commerçants
et les riverins une marche vient d'avoir
lieu en fin de semaine dernière et une
réunion se déroulera dans quelques jours
élection départementale en mars l'UMP
dévoile ses candidats pour un scrutin
profondément remagé objectif réaliser un
grand chlem la gauche en position très
délicate pour mars c'est quelques images
de la compagnie black blomur pour
débuter black Bamber les B3 qui fêtent
cette année leur 30 ans vendredi et
samedi soir au prismael en cour retour
là où tout a commencé pour cette
compagnie pionnière dans le monde de la
danse hiphop sur scène lors des deux
représentations de ce weekend on
retrouvait donc des anciens de la troupe
et des nouveaux venus pour un spectacle
fort en émotion reportage complet à
suivre dans une de nos prochaines
éditions 30 ans ce sera aussi bientôt
l'âge des Restos du cœur 21 décembre
1985 à Paris ouvre la première antenne
de distribution alimentaire au plus
démuni fondé par coluge 24 novembre 2014
ouverture de la 30e campagne d'hiver et
bonsoir henal vous êtes le responsable
communication pour le département
comment s déroulé cette première journée
que vous avez préparé vous me disiez
juste avant qu'on commence ce journal
depuis plus d'un mois en fait c'est ça
la première journée se passe bien il y a
aucun problème mais c'est parce que on
l'a préparé depuis déjà longtemps
c'estàd préparé
en en aval et en amont c'estàdire en
aval en cherchant on a reçu SEP camions
de de marchandise à peu près 170 tonnes
qu'on a mis en notre tropau des clés et
donc on a toute la semaine dernière on a
fait des navettes avec nos nos petits
camions et nos camionnettes pour
alimenter les 24 centres de de des
ivelines mais aussi en aval donc c'est
d'avoir rencontré c'est pendant tout le
mois de novembre on a rencontré tous les
gens qui veulent s'inscrire au resto du
cœur pour voir leurs besoins voilà c'est
ça au les restau du cœur les l'accueil
est inconditionnel tout le monde peut
frapper et surtout que c'est difficile
de frapper donc il est important qu'on
les accueille par contre la distribution
alimentaire le fait d'avoir une carte et
de pouvoir avoir de des des paniers
repas toutes les semaines ça il faut un
maximum de ressources en il y a un seuil
qui au-delà de ce seuil vous avez plus
le droit et donc on accueille les gens
on regarde et aussi on essaie de
d'évaluer qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
les amène quoi c'est est-ce que c'est
vraiment qu'un problème alimentaire en
général derrière le problème alimentaire
il y a toujours d'autres problèmes des
problèmes d'éducation des problèmes de
de logement des problèmes de travail et
là aussi les resto du cœur intervienne
on va venir dans un instant pour rester
sur la question de l'aide alimentaire
tout d'abord l'an dernier 130 millions
de repas distribués au niveau national
pour plus d'un million de personnes
c'est un triste record qui devrait une
fois de plus être battu pour le
département des ivelines ça représente
quoi alors pour le départ de excusez-moi
le département des hivelines on a
accueilli 14500 personnes et distribué
1400000 € pas l'année dernière et ce qui
est ce qui est frappant c'est
l'augmentation c'estàd l'augmentation
est de 13 % pour ce qu'on appelle les
adultes c'estàdire 1 an et plus et de 23
% pour ce qu'on les bébés c'està-dire de
0 à 1 an de 0 à 1 an et donc ça c'est
inquiétant c'est une augmentation
qu'onit en cette année d'avoir le même
type d'augmentation on peut pas savoirel
les gens vous avez rencontré depu mois
aujourd'hui oui on pense qu'on aura
encore une augmentation parce que la la
crise est là et donc on on n'est pas
sorti et et on le voit bien d'ailleurs
il y a de plus en plus de gens qui entre
guillemets redoublent c'està-dire que
avant au bout de 2 ans les gens sortent
des Restos du cœur et on reprenait une
activité maintenant les gens il restent
3 ans 4 ans la Deven une solution une
réponse qui que les gens attendent
chaque année pour venir vous voir on
parle justement du du profil type des
bénéficiaires souvent vous pose la
question mais année après année ça
évolue les femmes viennent plus souvent
les femmes seules les plus jeunes les
travailleurs pauvres c'est encore
il y a toujours toujours ça quoi des des
gens enfin c'est toujours des gens qui
sont sans ressources et quand même ce
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure une
forte montée des des mamans avec des
tout jeunes enfants qui n'ont pas les
moyens de se subvenir et donc c'est une
de nos un de nos challenges donc de
cette année d'ailleurs ça va être
justement de trouver de la nourriture
pour les jeunes bébés donc des petits
pots des couches des du lait infantile
et cetera ce que on na pas forcément
facilement voilà donc que les gens
n'hésitent pas à rentrer en contact avec
vous et puis les dons aussi c'est aussi
possible directement sur le site
internet et tout cela est défiscalisé
vous connaissez la
procédure juste une question par rapport
au nombre de centres dans le département
combien de bénévoles combien de centres
alors on a 24 centres plus deux resto
bébés c'estàdire deux centres qui sont
dédiés au bébés à poissi à rambouiller
autrement 24 centres et ce qu'on
voudrait c'est essayer d'en ouvrir un
autre à Sartrouville voilà c'està dire
on est on on couvre pas du tout
Versailles parce que c'est plutôt le
Secours Catholique on est plutôt la
vallée la la National 10 donc c'est
trappe coignère les essars rambouillé et
puis la vallée de la scène pour combien
de bénévoles et là on a 900 bénévoles
900 bénévoles qui interviennent et nous
sommes allés à leur rencontre dans l'un
des centres du département des evvelines
c'est à Rambouillet vendredi tout
dernier préparatif le reportage d'Antony
r plus de 700 kg de Dr viennent d'être
livré de l'autre côté la salle
d'inscription pour cette nouvelle
campagne ne désemplit pas dans cette
antenne des Restos du cœur 66 bénévoles
accueillent les familles en difficulté
notre rôle c'est de faire en sorte que
de pouvoir accueillir tous c tous ces
gens que ce soit pour la partie
alimentaire que pour l'aide à la
personne bien sûr parce qu'on ne fait
pas que de l'aide alimentaire on les
aide un peu dans leur démarche sur un de
domaines les restos du cœur lancent leur
30e campagne d'hiver àambouill une de
familles est déjà inscrite dont une
cinquantaine de mèr avec leurs bébés en
moyenne l'antenne rambolitaine distribue
2000 repas par semaine ici environ une
tonne et demi de nourriture est livrée
par semaine les restos du cœur se
battent contre le gaspillage alimentaire
aujourd'hui cela coûte moins cher aux
entreprises de jeter que de donner aux
associations les stocks il viennent ils
viennent essentiellement des restos bien
sûr il viennent aussi des collectes que
l'on peut faire il y a une collecte
nationale par an et puis les collectes
locales que l'on organise aussi et puis
donc les ce qu'on appelle n nos ramasses
dans les dans les magasins qui veulent
bien qui veulent bien N participer à ça
lors de la campagne 2013 2014
l'association créée par Coluche en 1985
a dépassé pour la première fois le
million de personnes inscrites dans ces
centres et servi 130 millions de repas
en
France nous continuons donc à ok cette
30e campagne des resto du cœur 30 30e
campagne d'hiver je précise d'hiver
parce que l'activité des restos ne
s'arrête jamais même l'été il y a des
distribution alimentaire on en parle
moins mais absolument c'estàdire que la
campagne d'hiver c'est le moment où on
réinscrit les gens et on lance tout un
processus et ensuite on a deux campagnes
une campagne de printemps qui fait mai
juin et puis une campagne d'automne qui
fait septembre octobre mais le gros
quand même de la nourriture est
distribué en hiver il n'y a pas que
l'aide alimentaire les restau
interviennent dans tous les domaines
l'hébergement pas seulement le
absolument c'estàdire le d'abord dans
chaque centre on essaie d'avoir
d'accueillir les gens et de les aider
donc on a de l'aide à l'informatique on
a de l'aide au devoir on a de la couture
de la cuisine de la coiffure ça dépend
des centres mais chaque centre a ses
spécificité en fonction du bénévole un
bénévole qui qui connaît qui est une
ancienne enseignante elle peut faire les
devoirs elle était coiffeuse elle peut
faire un salon de coiffure et puis on a
les les toits du cœur à poissie on a 10
appartements on accueille les g en
détresse qui en attendant le trouver une
autre solution et puis on a des ateliers
d'insertion où on essaie de remettre le
pied à l'étrier à des gens qui sont loin
de l'emploi vraiment l'IDE à l'insertion
c'est devenu une priorité pour les resto
pas uniquement dans le département mais
même au niveau national partout oui oui
ça se traduit comment cette aide à
l'insertion on a des ateliers et on
apprend aux gens à venir à l'heure à
partir à l'heure en étant sobre et de
faire ce qu'on demande de faire sans
enfin de façon de façon Natur
quels sont les premiers résultats que
vous avez pu obtenir justement alors les
résultats ce qu'on essaie d'avoir c'est
mais c'est très difficile c'est au moins
50 %
de de personnes qui après être passé
chez nous retrouve alors soit un CDD
soit un CDI soit une formation disons
une ce qu'on appelle une sortie positive
voilà et c'est difficile obtenir cette
50 c'est difficile ou alors tout le
problème voyz problème plus vous prenez
des gens qui sont loin de l'emploi plus
deendre des qui son prs de l'EMP c'est
bien de les prendre loin donc c'est pour
ça que c'est difficile et tout cela
nécessite de l'encadrement des bénévoles
est-ce que ces bénévoles sont toujours
plus nombreux estce qu'il est difficile
de recruter on est alors on est toujours
autour de 900 ça fait 7 ans que je suis
au resto du cœur et on est toujours
autour de 900 mais on manque de bénévole
dans certains métiers particuliers et
par exemple on nous a donné un gros
camion pour transporter et on a que deux
chauffeurs il nous en faudra au moins un
3è 4e parce qu'un bénévole travaille pas
euh 35 heur par semaine il travaille 2
jours donc si on veut utiliser le camion
tous les jours il nous faut au moins
trois bénévoles donc un chauffeur camion
si allez-y voilà le message est passé
sur les différents besoins en ce qui
concerne les bénévoles en ce qui
concerne dans la logistique aussi dans
la la chaîne du froid et puis localement
dans les différents centres de
distribution il y a toujours un besoin
qui je vous disais de la coiffure qui de
la cuisine qui de l'aide au devoir qui
de l'informatique apprend au gens parce
que quand vous êtes en recherche
d'emploi il faut savoir taper sur
ordinateur donc il faut il faut pouvoir
apprendre il faut il faut se connecter à
Pô emploi et cetera vous disiez ça fait
7 ans que vous êtes investi pour les
restos du cœur dans quel état d'esprit
vous êtes aujourd'hui lorsque vous voyez
que d'année année après année les
records sont malheureusement battu que
les restos sont là et sont là pour
longtemps encore je crois voilà c'est ça
c'est je pense que garder la même
motivation la même fois le même
engagement oui oui oui oui oui oui ou
oui parce que je pense qu'on est utile
voyez surtout moi qui suis à la retraite
ce que j'essaie c'est de de dire je
enfin d'être utile quoi et je pense que
là on est utile donc c'est c'est bien
mais quand je suis arrivé c'était donc
il y a 7 ans on était moins moins de
10000 personnes accueiles et maintenant
on est à 14500 plus 50 % quand même
rendez compte c'est c'est beaucoup et
pourtant les Yvelines c'est pas un
territoire vraiment pauvre qui on
pourrait on pourrait effectivement le
penser on va terminer cette séquence par
un micro trottoir notre question du jour
pensez-vous qu'un jour nous pourrions
réussir à nous passer des Restos du cœur
que les choses s'améliorent il faut
rester optimiste voici vos réponses
ah ça ça m'étonnerait ne plus avoir
besoin de rest du cœur ce serait bien
mais malheureusement ça m'a pas l'air
d'être bien parti pour ça ah non je
pense pas je pense que on aura toujours
besoin de ça
je crois pas non c'est très mal parti
non non ça ça va s gravement alors faut
espérer mais je vois pas tellement de
chance à ce sujet là non pas dans
l'immédiat en tout cas parce que je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup plus de pauvres
cette année que l'année dernière et que
l'année d'avant et que pour en l'instant
faut le garder alors je pense que au
contraire on en a de plus en plus
besoin voilà pour ce micro trottoir
malheureusement les restos du cœur sont
là et sont là pour longtemps ça veut
aussi dire que les pouvoirs publics que
les politiques ne prennent pas assez
leur part dans le règlement du problème
de la pauvreté je pense qu'ils font ce
qu'ils peuvent quoi mais que on peut pas
tout enfin un politique ne peut pas tout
alors on a on a devoir quand même pour
essayer de d'avoir plus de nourriture
not et manuel vas nous a été je sais pas
dans quel restaurant aujourd'hui et ce
qu'on cherche à faire c'est faire des
dons agricoles on voit bien que il y a
quand même beaucoup de gaspillage entre
la ferme la distribution et jusqu'à
votre frigidaire il se perd beaucoup de
nourriture donc est-ce qu'on pourrait
pas faire en sorte que quand des
agriculteurs ont des surplus qu'il les
donnent et puis qu'il ait un peu de
défiscalisation un petit encouragement
donc ça a été fait pour la filière du
lait il faudrait que ce soit plus fait
sur la filière de la viande
du air du blé et cetera donc là il y a
une voie un potentiel hein merci
beaucoup d'être passé ce soir en plateau
campagne des resto du cœur qui débute
aujourd'hui lundi 24 novembre vous
pouvez faire des dons notamment sur le
site internet de l'association resto
avec un S ducœur.org merci encore dans
l'actualité également les familles
plumées dans la rue plusieurs centaines
de personnes dimanche manifestaient dans
différentes villes à travers donc la la
France pour s'élever contre la réforme
des congés du congé parental et de la
modulation des
en fonction des revenus reportage sur la
manifestation de versaill avec Mélanie
Po et Patrick jacqu
de universalité et solidarité c'était
les mots d'ordre de cette manifestation
ils sont venus en famille avec poussette
et drapeau parce que tout simplement si
cette réforme passe c'est le début d'une
logique ou une fois de plus par rapport
à des aides qui se veulent universel
pour un projet global on dit les gens
qui gagnent plus que d'autres il vont
pas en profiter et en fait on pas
l'égalité non de faveur pour les
personnes quient plus qui sont censé
être des moteurs de de l'économie
française en fait on leur met toujours
plus sur le dos quoi et je trouve pas ça
logique normal il y a véritablement un
acharnement contre la famille et après
avoir défendu la famille père mère et
enfant je défends la famille sur le plan
financier des allocations familiales
divisées par de si vous gagner plus de
6000 € par mois et par 4 pour un revenu
supérieur à 8000 € el Mar Touren la
ministre des Affaires sociales 12 % des
familles seraient concerné jusqu'à
présent on cotise à la mesure de ce
qu'on gagne plus on gagne plus on cotise
mais on touche tous la même chose avec
cet amendement plus on gagne plus on
cotise mais plus plus on cotise moins on
va toucher donc il y a quelque chose qui
est profondément injuste trop c'est trop
le gouvernement a pris une série de
mesures qui déconstruisent la politique
familiale et nous pensons que ces
mesures sont
discriminatoire contreproductive et
particulièrement injuste ce que nous
demandons c'est parfaitement clair c'est
le retour à l'universalité de le
principe d'universalité des prestations
sociales et donc un moratoire sur ces
mesures qui arrivve les unes après les
autres sans qu'on ait pu mesurer
l'impact de la première selon un sondage
ifob publié ce mois-ci à la demande des
familles plumées 81 % des Français
estiment que la politique fiscale menée
par le gouvernement pénalise fortement
les familles 77 % craignent aussi que le
seuil de revenus à partir duquel ses
allocations seront réduites risque
d'être abaissé année après année la
réforme devrait rapporter 800 millions
d'économies par an elle devrait prendre
effet le 1er juillet
prochain autre manifestation ce weekend
à laavrière pour le retour à la
tranquillité publique dans le quartier
de la gare et dans le quartier d'Orly
parc également à rassemblement organisé
vendredi dernier élus association
habitants ont souhaité montrer leur
détermination à lutter contre les
trafics et les incidents qui se répètent
sur ce secteur yolen Tor et William l
pour les images à La Verrière les
résidents des quartiers d'Orly parc et
de la gare en ont marre dans ce quartier
le sentiment d'insécurité existe les
incidents se répètent et des trafics
illicites s'organise oh ben on a été
victime dans cette ville de voitures qui
ont brûlé des voitures cassées des gens
qui ont été agressés enfin et on en a
marre voilà c'est pas par la terreur
qu'on peut vivre c'est au contraire dans
la discussion et dans le débat que l'on
peut progresser pour un retour à un peu
plus de sérénité les élus associations
et habitants se sont rassemblés vendredi
dernier sur le parvis du centre
commercial malgré la surveillance mise
en place les actions de médiation ou
encore les animations diverse la
sérénité du quartier est toujours mise à
mal faut qu'à un moment donné on montre
que cet espace public appartient au
public que la rue appartient aussi à
ceux qui la font vivre que le commerce
doit pouvoir vivre normalement et donc
l'idée de montrer notre réaction
citoyenne quelque part le dispositif de
vidéo protection qui a pris du retard à
cause des difficultés techniques devrait
fonctionner d'ici 3 semaines afin de
préciser les mesures prises une réunion
publique se tiendra le lundi 8 décembre
à 18h30 à la maison de quartier d'Orly
parc et puisque nous parlions de
violence c'est aujourd'hui que c'est
ouvert dans les hautes scènes le procès
en appel de quatre rivelinois accusés du
lychage de Mohamed laiduni ils font
partie de la dizaine de personnes
condamnées l'an dernier à des peines de
4 à 20 ans de pris pour avoir roué de
coup ce jeune imprimeur sans histoire de
30 ans juin 2010 au volant de sa voiture
accompagné d'une partie de sa famille
les victime d'un accrochage à hauteur de
la 13 à hauteur des Mureaux les
responsables de l'accident refusent le
constat appel des amis le menace de mort
avant de passer à l'acte le procès en
appel se terminera le 5 décembre
politique à présent à l'UMP alors qu'au
niveau national tous les regards sont
tourné vers Nicolas Sarkozi et Alain
Jupé au lendemain d'un meeting assez
agité pour le maire de Bordeaux au
niveau local on prépare par les
élections départementales dans les
Yvelines l'UR est à l'Union union au
sein de la formation politique mais
aussi au-delà avec le Centre les
investitures pour le scrutin de mars
sont presque définitives le point avec
Catherine
zulato vendredi au Conseil Général des
Yvelines déjà dans les têtes les
élections départementales des 22 et 29
mars prochain avec une nouvelle règle il
n'y a plus 39 mais 21 cantons il n'y a
plus un conseiller général par canton
mais un binôme composé d'un homme et
d'une femme soit 42 élus la fédération
UMP des ivelines vient de dévoiler une
grande partie des candidats en Liss avec
une volonté d'union dès le premier tour
avec l'UDI pour faire barrage au Front
national notre volonté est de faire un
barrage parce que dans ce pays ce qui
est dramatique aujourd'hui c'est que
toutes les formations de gauche ont
l'air d'être très diminué électoralement
parlant ça veut dire que si la droite ne
s'unit pas avec le centre et si nous ne
faisons pas front dès le premier tour
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous ouvrez la
porte au Front National qui n'attend que
ça il n' est pas question autre objectif
avoué à demimot faire le grand schlem
certains cantons sont actuellement
détenus par la gauche c'est le cas du
canton de trappe Janine Marie candidate
sortante va se trouver opposé au maire
d'élencour Jean-Michel Fourgous vu la
situation d'abord
des budgétaire des des trois
communes bien sûr qu'il est urgent je
pense d' raccrocher ce canton les trois
communes la verrière trappe et l'ancour
à la majorité départementale parce que
si vous voulez des aides des moyens il
faut être dans la majorité moi je relève
le défi et j'y vais on va voir
maintenant si je si je perd j'assumerai
vous inquiétez pas mais voilà il je
pense qu' y a il AC la commune des
lancour qui peut il faut que soit un
responsable d'lancour qui aille pour
effectivement tenter ce canton qui est
effectivement très difficile d'accès oui
je pense que dans
cette situation territoriale avec là
encore un nouveau redécoupage la
personnalité de Jean-Michel peut faire
la différence c'est un candidat comme un
autre tout candidat mérite d'être
respecté moi je je tiens à ce qu'on
respecte mes convictions je respecte
aussi cell des autres toutes les
campagnes sont ardu et aucune n'est
jamais gagné d'avance Yvan Val sera
candidat sur le canton de morpa son binô
n'est pas encore connu mais son
suppléant si il s'agit de Grégor
garestier le nouveau maire de MPa morpa
c'est la commune la plus importante du
canton du N au canton donc il y a une
une certaine logique et puis il y a
aussi la volonté clairement d'amorcer un
renouvellement de génération travailler
ensemble ça va être l'occasion pour lui
de faire un tuilage progressivement
d'apprendre effectivement ce qu'est le
Conseil Général son mode de
fonctionnement et après je pense
qu'effectivement il sera prêt à assumer
les responsabilités de conseil général
un jour prochain à Rambouillet la
question n'est pas encore tranchée
Christine Boutin ne sait pas si elle
sera ou pas candidate je suis en train
de réfléchir ma décision n'est pas prise
définitivement pour savoir si je repars
ou pas donc j'ai demandé à l'UMP de
réserver ce canton j'ai l'habitude de
transmettre et donc voilà donc je je je
réfléchis encore on a un peu de temps
encore il faut voir qui peut se
présenter et comment on peut assurer la
véritable pérénité et la transmission de
tout ce que j'ai essayé de de faire dans
dans ce territoire je veux pas qu' s'y
passe n'importe quoi Christine Boutin
donnera sa position en début d'année
autre canton où la fédération
départementale a réservé sa décision
celui de montig le Bretonneux le canton
est pour l'heure détenu par le maire de
Guille en cour le socialiste François de
Ligier c'est un problème de profil c'est
un problème de nom c'est un problème de
décision parce que vous ne propulsez pas
quelqu'un comme ça pour être élu parce
que là nous parlons du binôme c'estàdire
de ceux qui deviendront conseillers
généraux dans les autres cantons de
notre secteur Philippe benasa nouveau
maire de boisarc sera candidat sur le
canton de saint-école à Plaisir Bertrand
coquer EDI fera équipe avec Joséphine
colvinberger la mère de plaisir reste
une interrogation la participation à ces
départementales et traditionnellement ce
ne sont pas les élections qui mobilisent
le plus et nous parlerons aussi des
départementales lors du prochain numéro
du 78 politique demain mardi 18h30 pour
la première diffusion en direct je
recevrai la responsable départemental du
Parti socialiste Benoît amont interpellé
par le Mouvement des Jeunes Communistes
des ivelines le MJCF souhaite rencontrer
le député socialiste de la 11e
circonscription qui s'est prononcé une
fois de plus ces derniers jours pour la
reconnaissance de la Palestine
parallèlement à cette demande 30000
pétitions pour la reconnaissance d'un
État palestinien seront déposé vendredi
28 novembre à l'Assemblée toujours par
le Mouvement des Jeunes Communistes on
passe au sport si vous aimez la course
automobile vous avez forcément suivi ce
weekend le Grand Prix de Formule 1 mais
les vrais passionnés était un mort pas
pour les 6 heur d'endurance du club de
modélisme la section slot racing du MMC
a fait tourn ces bolides nous y étions
Anthony
reche des vitesses de pote allant
jusqu'à 400 km/h un tour bouclé en 7
secondes bienvenue dans le monde du slot
pour cette 8e édition des 6h de morpa
Neu équipes de trois pilotes
s'affrontent sur un cercuit de si vois à
l'échelle 1 32e et ici nous sommes loin
du simple jeu offert à Noël aux enfants
en endurance la prime est à la
régularité du chronomètre la
concentration devient alors la base la
précision vital ça paraît extrêmement
facile et d'ailleurs c'est pas très
compliqué pour avoir un un niveau moyen
par contre c'est c'est un jeu d'adresse
ça va être comme du tir à l'arc ou du
tir à la carabine il va falloir faire
toujours le même geste être le plus
précis possible et c'est un véritable
jeu d'adresse et pour aller chercher les
derniers cè et les derniers 10è c'est
des heures et des heures et des heures
d'entraînement la dextérité des pilote
est d'autant plus sollicité sur cette
course que chaque dernier quart d'heure
de session se conclut en nocturne dans
le slot le pilotage est tout aussi
important que la performance intrinsèque
de la voiture car détrompez-vous même à
l'échelle un 32e le moindre détail de
préparation compte les autos en général
c'est les équipes qui les fournissent
elles se préparent selon un règlement
technique donc les les voitur on essaie
de les adapter le mieux possible à la
piste à sa forme s'il y a très longue
lign droite par exemple on va mettre des
transmissions très longues s'il y a très
peu de ligne droite on va mettre des
transmissions très courtes et cetera les
pneus aussi sont importants malgré la
compétition la convivialité règne dans
une discipline où l'on peut devenir le
roi des circuits pour quelques dizaines
d'euros une poignée d'assez bonne
qualité il faut compter une cinquantaine
d'euros après on a des poigné plus cher
parce que là on fait appel à
l'électronique au niveau d'un véhicule
un 32e avec une voiture à 50 € on peut
déjà bien s'amuser sur leur nouvelle
piste en bois les pilotes de morpa
s'imposent à domicile au terme des 6hur
de course après
2790 tours
parcourus l'essentiel du sport ce sera
avec Antony juste après ce journal comme
chaque lundi si vous n'avez pas eu
l'occasion de célébrer Halloween cette
année l'association roller pux vous
offrait ce weekend une séance de
rattrapage samedi après-midi originalité
de mise au gymnase intercommunal du mil
Saint-Denis puisque c'est une rollur
partie sur ce thème qui était proposé
piste de danse animation goûter le
programme c'est plus tourner vers les
familles donc parents enfants et c'est
pour qu'ils profitent du roller
aujourd'hui où c'est un jour d'automne
bon il y a pas grand chose à faire et ça
fait une bonne après-midi conviviale et
familiale BRI c'est enfin il y a plein
de musique c'est trop bien oua il y a
plein de fumé c'est très festif c'est
bien sympathique mes filles qui tournent
elles aiment ça c'est sur ces images que
se termine cette édition du lundi 24
novembre je vous retrouve demain à 18h
toujours en direct excellente soirée sur
TV
fil